ça augmentera leurs chances de survie.
Très tôt dans son développement, un petit essai a été réalisé
sur un peu moins de cent patients.
50 patients ont reçu de la lorcaïnide, et parmi eux, 10 sont morts.
50 autres patients ont reçu un placebo
ne contenant pas d'ingrédient actif, et un seul d'entre eux est mort.
On a donc, à juste titre, conclu que le médicament était un échec,
et son développement commercial a été arrêté,
et parce que son développement commercial a été arrêté, cet essai n'a jamais été publié.
Malheureusement, au cours des 5 à 10 années suivantes,
d'autres compagnies ont eu la même idée : que des médicaments
empêcheraient les arythmies chez des gens ayant eu des crises cardiaques.
Ces médicaments ont été mis sur le marché. Ils ont été prescrits
très largement, parce que les crises cardiaques sont très courantes,
et ils nous a fallu si longtemps pour découvrir que ces médicaments
étaient la cause d'une augmentation du taux de mortalité
qu'avant que nous détections ce signal de sécurité,
plus de 100 000 personnes étaient déjà mortes inutilement en Amérique
suite à la prescription de médicaments antiarythmiques.
En fait, en 1993,
les chercheurs qui avaient fait cette étude en 1980, cette première étude,
ont publié un mea culpa, des excuses à la communauté scientifique,
où ils disaient : « Quand nous avons fait notre étude en 1980,
nous pensions que l'augmentation du taux de décès qui survenaient
dans le groupe de la lorcaÏnide était un effet du hasard.
Le développement de la lorcaïnide a été abandonné pour des raisons commerciales,
et cette étude n'a jamais été publiée ;
c'est désormais un bon exemple d'un parti pris de publication.
C'est le terme technique pour le phénomène où
des données peu flatteuses sont perdues, ne sont pas publiées,
sont portées disparues et ils disent que les résultats décrits ici
« auraient pu fournir un premier avertissement de problèmes à venir. »
Ce sont des anecdotes de science élémentaire.
Ce sont des anecdotes d'il y a 20 ou 30 ans.
Le milieu des publications universitaires est très différent maintenant.
Il existe des revues universitaires comme Trials, la revue en accès libre,
qui publie tout essai conduit sur des humains
que son résultat soit positif ou négatif.
Mais ce problème de résultats négatifs qui disparaissent
prévaut toujours. En fait il prévaut tellement
qu'il touche au coeur de la médecine factuelle.
Voici donc un médicament appelé réboxétine, et c'est un médicament
que j'ai moi-même prescrit. C'est un antidépresseur.
Je suis un médecin très impliqué, alors j'ai lu toutes les études
que je pouvais sur ce médicament. J'ai lu l'étude qui a été publiée
et qui montrait que la réboxétine faisait mieux que le placebo,
et j'ai lu les trois autres études qui ont été publiées
et qui montraient que la réboxétine était aussi valable que n'importe quel anti-dépresseur.
Parce que ce patient-là avait mal réagit aux autres antidépresseurs,
j'ai pensé que la réboxétine irait aussi bien. Qu'il fallait l'essayer.
Mais la suite m'a donné tort. En fait,
sept essais ont été menés, ils comparaient la réboxétine
à un placebo. L'une d'elles
était positive et a été publiée, mais les six autres
étaient négatives et ne l'ont pas été.
3 essais ont été publiés, ils comparaient la réboxétine
à d'autres antidépresseurs, et la réboxétine y faisait tout aussi bien.
Ils ont été publiés,
mais trois fois plus de données de patients ont été recueillies
montrant que la réboxétine était pire que
ces autres traitements, Ces essais là n'ont pas été publiés.
J'avais été induit en erreur.
Vous pourriez dire, c'est un exemple extrême,
et je ne voudrais pas être coupable du même genre
de sélection arbitraire et de référencement sélectif
dont j'accuse les autres.
Mais il s'avère que ce phénomène de parti-pris de publication
a en fait été très étudié.
Voici donc un exemple de la façon de l'aborder.
Le modèle classique est de prendre un tas d'études
dont vous savez qu'elles ont été conduites à leur terme,
et de voir si elles ont été publiées quelque part
dans les revues académiques. Il a donc fallu prendre tous les essais
jamais fait sur les antidépresseurs
et approuvés par la FDA sur une période de 15 ans.
Ils ont pris tous les essais soumis à la FDA comme partie intégrante du processus d'approbation.
Il n'y a donc pas tous les essais déjà réalisés sur ces médicaments,
parce qu'on ne peut jamais savoir si on les a,
mais ce sont ceux qui ont été menées afin d'obtenir l'autorisation de commercialisation.
Ils sont ensuite allés voir si ces essais avaient été publiés
dans les revues scientifiques revues par des pairs. Voilà ce qu'ils ont trouvé.
C'est à peu près une répartition 50-50. En fait, la moitié de ces essais
étaient positifs, la moitié étaient négatifs.
Mais quand ils sont allés chercher ces essais dans les revues scientifiques revues par des pairs,
ils ont trouvé une image très différente.
Seuls trois des essais négatifs ont été publiés,
mais tous les essais positifs ont été publiés, sauf un.
Si nous comparons ces deux illustrations, en passant rapidement de l'une à l'autre,
vous pouvez voir quelle différence énorme il y avait
entre la réalité et ce que les médecins, patients,
commissaires des services de santé et des universitaires
ont pu voir dans les revues scientifiques revues par des pairs
On nous a induit en erreur, et il s'agit d'une erreur systématique
au coeur de la médecine.
En fait, il y eu tant d'études réalisées sur
le parti-pris des publications maintenant, plus d'une centaine, qu'elles ont été
recueillies dans une révision systématique, publiée en 2010,
qui a pris toutes les études sur le parti-pris des publications
qu'on pouvait trouver.
Le parti-pris des publications affecte tous les domaines de la médecine.
Environ la moitié de tous les essais, en moyenne, sont portés disparus au combat,
et nous savons que les résultats positifs sont près de deux fois plus susceptibles
d'être publiés que les résultats négatifs.
Il s'agit d'un cancer au cœur de la médecine factuelle.
Si j'ai tiré à pile ou face une pièce 100 fois mais ensuite
je vous ai caché les résultats de la moitié de ces lancers,
je pourrais donner l'impression d'avoir une pièce qui tombe toujours sur pile.
Mais ça ne signifierait pas que j'avais une pièce avec deux piles.
Ça voudrait dire que je suis un arnaqueur
et que vous êtes idiot de me laisser m'en tirer. (Rires)
Mais c'est exactement ce que nous tolérons aveuglément
de toute la médecine factuelle.
Et pour moi, c'est une faute délibérée de recherche.
Si j'ai mené une étude et j'ai caché
la moitié des points de données de cette étude,
vous pourriez à juste titre m'accuser, en gros, de fraude de recherche.
Et pourtant, pour une raison quelconque, si quelqu'un effectue
10 études mais ne publie que les cinq qui donnent le résultat qu'ils veulent,
nous ne considérons pas qu'il s'agit d'une faute délibérée de recherche.
Et lorsque cette responsabilité est diffusée entre
tout un réseau de chercheurs, d'universitaires,
de commanditaires de l'industrie, de rédacteurs en chef de revues, pour une raison quelconque
nous estimons que c'est plus acceptable,
mais l'effet sur les patients est accablant.
Et ça se passe maintenant, aujourd'hui.
Il s'agit d'un médicament appelé Tamiflu. Le Tamiflu est un médicament
pour lequel les gouvernements du monde entier ont dépensé des milliards
et des milliards de dollars pour en faire des stocks,
et nous avons stocké le Tamiflu dans la panique,
dans l'espoir qu'il permettra de réduire le taux de complications de la grippe.
Complications est un euphémisme médical pour une pneumonie
et la mort. (Rires)
Mais lorsque les examinateurs systématiques de Cochrane
tentaient de rassembler toutes les données, de tous les essais
qui avaient déjà été menés pour savoir si le Tamiflu le faisait vraiment ou pas,
ils ont constaté que plusieurs de ces essais n'étaient pas été publiés.
Les résultats n'étaient pas disponibles pour eux.
Et quand ils ont commencé à obtenir les critiques de ces essais par divers moyens,
par des demandes selon la loi de la liberté d'information,
en harcelant divers organismes, ce qu'ils ont trouvé était incohérent.
Et quand ils ont essayé de mettre la main sur les rapports des études cliniques,
des documents de 10 000 pages qui avaient
le meilleur rendu possible de l'information,
on leur a dit qu'ils n'avaient pas l'autorisation de les avoir.
Et si vous voulez lire la correspondance complète,
les excuses et les explications fournies par l'industrie pharmaceutique,
vous pouvez voir ça dans l'édition de cette semaine
de PLOS Medicine.
La chose la plus incroyable dans tout ça, selon moi,
est que non seulement c'est un problème, non seulement nous reconnaissons
qu'il s'agit d'un problème, mais nous avons eu à supporter des corrections bidons.
Nous avons eu des gens qui ont prétendu qu'il s'agit d'un problème résolu.
Tout d'abord, nous avons eu les registres des essais et tout le monde a dit :
Oh, c'est bon. Nous demanderons à tout le monde d'enregistrer leurs essais, ils posteront le protocole,
ils diront ce qu'ils vont faire avant qu'ils ne le fassent,
et puis après nous pourrons vérifier et voir si tous les essais qui
ont été réalisées et terminées ont été publiés.
Mais les gens ne s'embêtent pas à tenir ces registres.
Et donc, l'International Committee of Medical Journal Editors est venu,
et ils ont dit : oh, Eh bien, nous n'abandonnerons pas.
Nous ne publierons aucune revue, nous ne publierons aucun essai,
à moins qu'ils n'aient été enregistrés avant d'être commencé.
Mais ils n'ont pas résisté. En 2008, une étude a été réalisée
qui montrait que la moitié de tous les essais publiés par des revues
édités par les membres de l'ICMJE
n'étaient pas été correctement enregistrés, et un quart d'entre eux n'étaient pas enregistrés du tout.
Et puis enfin, le FDA Amendment Act a été adopté
il y a 2 ans, et il dit que quiconque effectue
un essai doit publier les résultats de cet essai dans l'année.
Et dans le BMJ, dans la première édition de janvier 2012,
vous pouvez voir une étude qui cherche à voir si les gens
respectent cette décision, et il s'avère que seulement un sur cinq
l'ont fait.
C'est un désastre.
Nous ne pouvons pas connaître les effets réels des médicaments
que nous prescrivons si nous n'avons pas accès
à toutes les informations.
Ce n'est pas un problème difficile à résoudre.
Nous devons forcer les gens à publier tous les essais
menés chez l'homme, y compris les essais plus anciens,
parce que le FDA Amendment Act demande seulement de publier les essais réalisés après 2008,
et je ne sais pas dans quel monde nous ne pratiquons la médecine
que sur la base d'essais terminés au cours des deux dernières années.
Nous devons publier tous les essais chez l'homme,
y compris les essais plus anciens, pour tous les médicaments actuellement utilisés,
et vous devez dire à tous ceux que vous connaissez
qu'il s'agit d'un problème et qu'il n'a pas été corrigé.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)
(Applaudissements)